this weekend pbs aired a charlie brown
christmas
as well as a surprise trailer
for a brand new peanut special
that's more appropriate for our times
take a look
this christmas it's charlie brown as
you've never seen him before
despite the president's allegations of
widespread voter fraud
still no evidence has been found it's
2020 charlie brown
a timely update on your favorite classic
characters
no ma'am i haven't heard of a wuhan you
say it came from a bat
i'm depressed i've been hit hard
financially by this pandemic
well as a psychiatrist i'm making more
money than ever
i'm going to write you a script for
lexapro watch as the peanuts gang
deals with the problems of today linus
your camera's on
we can see you sucking your thumb
charlie brown
don't you realize that systemic racism
is foundational to american society
and all the fun of 2020. in q's last
drop
he said the bird is singing because the
storm is coming
this is more evidence that the
coronavirus was created in a lab by the
cia
can you play wet ass [ __ ] it's 2020
charlie brown
available wherever vhs tapes are sold
you